depuis 24 heures l'indiscrétion selon
laquelle l'elysée s'inquiéterait d'une
candidature surprise de cyril hanouna a
beaucoup fait réagir pour ceux acquis
l'information aurait échappé la chaîne
d'information continue bfm a révélé en
début de semaine que certains ministres
serait inquiet d'une candidature à la
coluche
concernant l'élection présidentielle de
2022 comprenez un candidat surprise
issus du monde du spectacle qui pourrait
venir chambouler l'élection est
redistribué les cartes
et selon ces mêmes ministres c'est cyril
hanouna qui serait le plus à même de
remplir ce rôle
cyril s'est amusé de la situation
nombreuses ont été les réactions ces
dernières heures concernant cette
potentielle candidature sur les réseaux
sociaux pour le moment baba n'a pas
souhaité communiquer sur la composition
de son futur gouvernement
alors d'après vous les médias et les
politiques craignent t-il la candidature
de cyril hanouna à la présidentielle de
2000 22
alors c'est vrai que depuis hier c'est
une vraie rigolade parce que les aigris
sont de sortie il y en a plein qui ont
profité au fait du sujet pour me tacler
regardé hier sur sud radio
c'était un festival veut dire ce que
vous en pensez après autour de la table
qui votera nous n'allons en 2022 si
jamais pourquoi pas vous n'empêche que
j'ai le sens du ridicule et lui au figés
fpr est toujours 94 % de nos auditeurs
qui ne votent pas pour hanouna et ce
commentaire de michel après un président
qui nous fait pleurer voilà qu'on nous
propose un qui veut nous faire rire tout
part en cacahuète et peut-être aussi un
nom à un jour et est candidat et puis
élu il aura besoin de faire de la
câlinothérapie tellement ils risquent de
faire des âneries mais là j'ai eu des
spécialistes en avril est-ce que vous
feriez pour alinéa vous tient à bon
pourquoi quelqu'un qui le la politique
quelqu'un qui fait le buzz comme
président de la république c'est pas
pour rire c'est pas pourrir donc on peut
allumer la télé rigoler l'a été après un
président de la république s'est pas
pourrir donc qu'il fasse vraiment
l'attention au moment où ils vont où ils
vont aller voter et féconde et à dori
vous avez dit clairement que vous
n'étiez pas candidat et oui mais bon ils
veulent faire du buzz de sud radio s'est
pas beaucoup écouté on les comprend mais
j'ai entendu quelque chose qui m'a
choqué et qui m'a vraiment intéressé
c'est que pourquoi aujourd'hui les gens
s'intéressent à vous et peut-être
également le peuple français
commençaient à penser pourquoi parce
qu'on est le seul pays en france que je
vous dis est vrai ou le dernier
président qu'on avait il eu c'est à dire
françois hollande n'a jamais jamais
travaillé de sa vie il est sorti de
l'ena il n'a jamais un contrat un cd
un cd ou un cdi monter une société il
n'a jamais travaillé une aidé quelqu'un
qui avait dit la france est le seul pays
où un homme politique c'est un métier
est aujourd'hui les français veulent je
pense comme dans d'autres pays que les
gens qu'on puisse élire soit des gens
bas qui ont travaillé qui ont connu des
choses qu'ils savent que c'est qu'une
société et tout ça je pense que à merci
forcément ça fait beaucoup et ça répond
plus qu'aujourd'hui on attend c'est
peut-être pas plus aujourd'hui qu'un
chien homme politique c'est un métier
évidemment ils travaillent bien mais ce
que je veux c'est surtout parce que
cyril serait ce serait très très bien
s'entourer des bonnes personnes et les
pas idiot a accusé bernard tapie outre
la réussite c'est savoir s'entourer
il serait s'entourer et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'effectivement oui on sera sur
un vrai pourcentage alors ce matin il ya
eu une meuf qui m'a fait vraiment
rigoler c'était chez jean marc morandini
sur ces nous dit blement elle a pas trop
confiance en moi regardez j'ai plein de
rigolade à tonnerre à l'assemblée
cyrille eldin qui a été demandé leur
avis devrait voir ses énormes regarde
tout cas si les gens ont besoin d'autre
chose c'est peut-être de quelqu'un qui
écoute et pas forcément quelqu'un qui
gouverne
on va là où je veux en venir après
attention président et gouverne mais
j'ai dit oui mais écoutez j'ai dit
l'aimer écouter osé agir et mais est
bouclée aux écoles on imagine quand même
pas celle avec le bouton du club et je
pense qu'ils sont en panique parce
qu'effectivement le fait qu'on
réfléchisse sur vous ça veut dire que
peut-être vous allez vous avez dit que
vous ne gagnez pas mais s'il ya une
place à prendre
il ya une place à prendre aujourd'hui
par sais pas ce que vous imaginez 15%
10%
même sans qu'on soit c'était non là
pardon mais sur le sondage sud radio
mais les critiques de 6%
c'est non sans pour autant sombrer dans
le reer pour tout d'un coup politique
c'est plus que le fameux la maison
attention si vous croisez un camion of
which il en fait pour répondre à la
question sans même être candidat et en
ayant dit que vous ne le sauriez pas
récepteurs aux états majors politiques
pourquoi il ya quatre raisons très
rapidement parce que d'après eux et ce
dix ce serait le candidat de la
réconciliation lui seul parle à tous les
âges aux français de toutes origines
aucun homme politique ne le fait vous
n'êtes pas du sérail deuxième raison ils
ne savent pas comment vous attaquer ils
se disent mais comment on va lui ai
parlé il a son boulot il a dit matters
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir lui
trouver y aura jamais d'emplois fictifs
chez vous la troisième raison la
troisième raison qui sont aidées
[Applaudissements]
après ça de la peau de chamois pour
terminer j'aimerais c'est que vous avez
l'aura et la puissance médiatique et la
quatrième raison c'est que ils craignent
pour 2022 une élection ils craignent
redoute peu à l'américaine
il y avait eu kennedy a vu obama ya très
peu de ces réseaux sociaux trump il a
dit j'ai pas besoin de médias j'ai mon
propre média je suis mon média mais vous
vous de puissance sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est du jamais vu en france c'est vrai
ça ou qui se disent dans une île où est
directe on touche directement les gens
plus d'intercesseur faire personne il va
parler aux gens et va bien donc vous
dire aujourd'hui vous commencez à
survivre alors il à nicolas canteloup
que j'aime beaucoup qui m'a mis un petit
hack ce matin aussi très drôle regarder
une colonne des hypothèses les plus
redoutés serait cyril hanouna bruno le
maire vous voulez réagir
oui bonjour mais petite beauté une telle
candidature serait positive matthieu
delormeau ferait un excellent mise la
culture à n'en pas douter qu'à
l'intérieur est ce que vous verriez une
différence réelle entre christophe
castaner et benjamin castaldi compromis
s'il faudrait quelqu'un côté lui de
rodez enfin je ne suis pas dans une
démarche personnelle même si c'est vrai
j'ai déjà mis des nouilles dans mon slip
ce matin et j'ai repris la danse des
sardines écouter de toute façon à baba
de trancher alors que nicolas canteloup
très drôle et julie voilà qui nous amène
un petit tacle comme d'habitude ça nous
a jamais cessé vous savez que a parlé à
vous énormément en france mais avec eux
on a parlé d' hanouna dans le monde
entier dans le monde entier on a parlé
de vous les gens les plus influents de
la planète ont repris l'info mais je ne
sais pas des conneries il yad'autres les
chars de boules mais des gens
extrêmement influents dans le monde
entier se sont interrogés sur le fait
que vous seriez candidats et on a les
images c'est vrai qu'après on aura du
vrai avec cyrille eldin alors j'ai
appris que cyril hanouna se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle
mon esprit enfin trouver la paix
intérieure s'il est élu vous changerez
de nom
pour devenir le dalaï d'art cas lorsque
la maison blanche m'a appuyé la
candidature de cyril hanouna
mes yeux se sont remplis de larmes de
joie je suis vraiment impatient de
travailler avec lui une chance là il va
être élu président à
je suis ravi que mon petit loukoum se
présente l'élection dès 2021
s'il est élu j'ai donné sa première dame
et je m'occuperai de sa marque et
messieurs
il m'a répondu aux puces à introd
journaliste chouly éditoriale c'est
dominique de montvalon et voilà qui m'a
défendu
voyons ça m'a touché parce que c'est du
lourd le gard cyril hanouna il a il a
une caractéristique parmi dorothea lange
outre sa capacité d écoute indiscutable
il a une caractéristique c'est l'un des
très rares qui serait capable
aujourd'hui de réunir l'ensemble des
potentiellement l'ensemble des gilet
jaune ceux qui sont plutôt issus de la
droite ceux qui sont plutôt issus de la
gauche et c'est donc il a une capacité
fédératif qui existe c'est l'un des
rares qui peut fédérer des antilles
macro qui au pied de l'urne au se divise
c'était mon patron au parisien c'est un
genre et ce grand monsieur et vous
apprécie énormément
oui et alors cyrille eldin est allé
demander aux députés députés ce qu'il
pensait de mon éventuelle candidature en
2022 il est parti prendre le pouls à
l'assemblée directement c'était tout à
l'heure regardez les réponses et
offusquons à même la répondre à leurs
actions une petite fraction du ministre
de l'intérieur christophe castaner garde
il faut déjà lu s'étonner de rien en
politique j'ai déjà fait élire un enfant
président mais cyril hanouna classe pour
cent ça c'est étonnant aussi un candidat
sérieux
c'est pas parce qu'il présente une
émission qui n'est pas un candidat c'est
un candidat sérieux c'est un candidat
qui rassemble sur son nom un score qui
lui permet d'être second tour hanouna
créditée de 15% d'intentions de vote
pour le premier tour de la
présidentielle
ça n'existe pas pourquoi parce que ça
n'existe pas s'il a cette cote de
popularité ce qu'il a donné la parole au
gilet jaune je vois et que une fois de
plus ils lâchent pas la faire sur le
fait qu' on peut tous vivre ensemble
quels que soient nos convictions
spirituelles et c'est moi c'est plutôt 5
à mon avis dans son image je peux me
planter à none à 15% vous ne voulez pas
passer passées commencent à passer vous
pensez qu'ils méritaient plus très plus
rayhana qui aimeraient le voir à 30%
passer au premier tour
ça me rappelle qu'au lüscher une époque
vous savez ce qu'il en est advenu est
mort non il n'a pas été candidat
paraît que mâcon claque un peu du
fessier que cellule de crise à l'elysée
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais j'en
pense rien zoom gens pensent tout le
monde évite de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle s'ils trouvent le nombre
de parrainages de maires noter que des
pays européens dans lesquels on voit des
gens qui émerge très vite il est bien
pensé que ce sera pour la france un
président plutôt dark a plutôt rare à
amay vous savez qu'il faut suis pas
d'être candidat pour être élu oui mais
s'ils gagnent à 6 gagne je pense que je
pense qu'on va pas s'ennuyer tous les
jours pour vos petits le mieux
rassembler la gauche quand mélenchon par
exemple en ont mais après ça situe pas
du tout sûre même temps ce que ça
démonte c'est ce qu'on a eu pendant la
dernière élection présidentielle c'est
une grande crise du politique à sauver
monde parce qu'il n'est pas candidat
parce que d'équipés qui va avoir envie
de se présenter va redescendre en plus
non mais je m'ennuie je pense à jour
pareil - tu es candidat [ __ ] et
populaire on l'a vu avec culot quoi
qu'on lui doit et ministre cote de
popularité un peu baisser dès qu'il sort
il remonte et c'est ce qu'on m'a dit sur
vous quoi vous auriez produisent
d'hanouna cyril la question mais oui
mais non mais vous savez moi je vous
êtes complémentaires parce qu'elle a un
des deux qui est drôle
merci c'est lequel hanouna 15%
d'intentions de vote contre mâcon vous y
croyez olala castanet soutien alors là
revirement de situation
[Applaudissements]
j'accepte bien